astonishing performance everybody
nervous watching but it seemed like a
completely nerveless performance from
the 18 year old from bromley who's taken
new york by storm she had to earn the
right to even be in this tournament she
had to come through three qualifying
matches she's now won six matches in the
main draw one match now stands between
her and becoming the us open champion
she's the first ever qualifier to reach
this stage of the tournament and what
style she did it in she came in as the
underdog against maria sakari the world
ranked 17 player a 26 year old who's had
a wealth of experience at this level
she's been in grand slam finals before
but she wilted under the power of the
racket of emiraticanu and she really was
blown away by the composure the control
the completeness of emma radakani's game
she broke her twice in the first set to
take that set 6-1 broke her again in the
second set to take that set 6-4 it took
her just 84 minutes to gain access to
that grand slam final a really really
incredibly impressive performance a
maturity far beyond her age and
that maturity it has to be said extends
beyond the court her responsibilities
here off the court she's become a fan
favorite over the past two weeks in new
york she's developed a trademark for
walking around the court after those
victories taking pictures with fans
posing for selfies and then posting
those selfies um on her social media
platforms she also very much holds her
own in interviews she's only 18 years
old as we keep saying but she really
does um give an incredibly impressive
account of herself i've just been um
listening into the post-match press
conference that she's giving at the
moment she was asked about her parents
not being able to travel to the to the
us to be here in new york to watch her
in the final due to the travel
restrictions the covey travel
restrictions here she said yes it's
disappointing but she knew that that was
the situation before this tournament and
she again paid credit to the team that
are around her her coach her
psychologist her agent who are here with
her in new york and she was asked about
whether she feels the pressure going
into the final now she reminded everyone
that she is only a qualifier here the
first ever qualifier to reach this stage
of the tournament so she said the
pressure is not on her
now there is another teenager waiting
for her in the final 19 year old leila
fernandez from canada who qualified for
that final in equally impressive style
beating the world number two arena
sabalenka fairly easily in the end
although there were some incredible
rallies between the two in that match
certainly a tougher a tougher opponent
than ever emma radacano faced now as you
mentioned there it has been an
incredibly rapid rise for the youngster
she was ranked outside the world top 350
just three months ago this is only her
second ever grand slam performance and
just to give you an idea of how
impressive it's been she's earned 900
000 pounds in prize money already here
in new york that's over triple what
she's earned in her entire career
so far she'll be hoping to go one better
on saturday though